[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich starte so richtig
in jeder modellreihe mit einer
traditionellen marokkanischen
fastensuppe nanz harrieder und die ist
wirklich unglaublich lecker tod im magen
sehr gut nach dem fasten denn die ist
ein typischer weise zum fastenbrechen zu
mister dann wenn die sonne untergeht und
jetzt super gute zutaten wie koriander
sellerie linsen kichererbsen wer mag
sogar fleisch also ich bin super
gespannt was sie sagt das rezept für
mich von meiner marokkanischen
schwägerin wege gehen ich fand's super
und ich möchte das gerne so an euch
weitergeben ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz
viel spaß bei der zubereitung wir
benötigen rindfleisch das habe ich in
kleine stücke geschnitten
außerdem geschälte tomaten linsen ihr
könnt zum beispiel auch die roten linsen
nehmen petersilie und koriander die habe
ich beide sehr fein gehackt außerdem
faden nudeln und kichererbsen wir sind
bei mir zum beispiel aus der dose
außerdem eine fein gehackte zwiebel
olivenöl tomatenmark und an gewürzen
salz weißem pfeffer kurkuma sind
irgendwie und kreuzkümmel dann benötigen
wir noch staudensellerie das ist auch
ganz typisch und natürlich ganz viel
leitungswasser für die suppe ich sag
euch im laufe des videos noch welche
zutaten in zum beispiel austauschen
könnt oder welche ihr weglassen können
denn falls ihm irgendwas nicht findet
dann gibt es da eigentlich immer eine
lösung die tomaten habe ich jetzt
gehäutet und den festen harten strunk
entfernt und bevor wir jetzt den top
aufsetzen müssen dass auf jeden fall
vorbereiten und zwar tour ihren wer
jetzt das ganze meint uhr ihr stab hängt
gerade am akku kannten die thema end
geben
so und jetzt einfach nur püriert und
dann zeige ich euch die staudensellerie
und dann geht es schon weiter
[Musik]
sobald alles dann püriert ist geht es
auch schon weiter mit der
staudensellerie das sind auch sowie zwei
sachen die muss man vorbereitet und
alles andere müsste ja nur schnippeln
also so lange dauert es gar nicht jetzt
nehme ich hier mein schneidebrett und
wir brauchen ungefähr so drei vier
stangen davon
ich habe zwar schon vorbereitet deswegen
lege ich die zwei weg und wichtig ist
dass ich natürlich wäscht und dann
schneidet ihr vorne dieses helle einmal
weg und wir brauchen beides also wir
brauchen hier sowohl das hier als auch
hier vorne die blätter aber ich kümmere
mich jetzt zuallererst um nicht standard
also hier werden jetzt zuallererst die
fasern entfernt die sind zwar auch super
gesund und haben viele ballaststoffe
aber die sind in der suppe einfach nicht
so angenehm und deshalb nimmt euch jetzt
einfach einem sparschäler oder messer
und dann geht ihr von der oberfläche
hier einmal entlang und entfernt diese
sehen also diese dieser phase ii vorne
sobald ihr das dann erledigt habt
schneidet ihr das einfach in kleine
stücke und am besten mixed ihr das dann
in so einem blender damit es auch
wirklich total fein ist hier hab ich ja
schon vorbereitet haben wir zeit mal
eben hier
das habe ich hier schon vorbereitet das
sind zwei solcher starke und jetzt gebe
ich die dritte noch mit dazu und mixt
das auch noch mal gut um
[Musik]
also das habe ich jetzt vorbereitet und
jetzt geht's an die blätter die brauchen
wir nämlich auch hier nehme ich mir
jetzt hier so ab und dann schneide ich
dir auch richtig richtig weil ich habe
das auch schon vorbereitet und mach das
jetzt mit dem rest auch noch
[Musik]
so das gebe ich jetzt noch mit zum riff
wie gesagt das war mir nur wichtig das
zu zeigen weil als ich das erste mal
eine staudensellerie der hand hatte hey
wie mach ich dass jetzt der haben sie
dachte dass jan baum dann habe ich das
gezeigt so fallen sollte das schon sein
also ich finde man ihr feiner desto
besser deswegen habe ich das auch mit
der petersilie und mit dem koriander
genauso fein gemacht und mit der zwiebel
so jetzt geht es weiter mit dem topf und
da bereite ich kurz alles vor ort sehen
uns gleich wieder
zuallererst wird jetzt das fleisch kurz
angebraten im öl also wirklich nur ganz
kurz scharf anbraten und dazu muss ich
auch sagen ihr müsst nicht unmengen
fleisch benutzen
manche dem auch ein schönes großes
fertiges stück fleisch und braten das an
einfach nur für den geschmack und manche
machen auch komplett ohne fleisch weil
es im hauptgericht vielleicht auch schon
fleisch gibt aber ich mache das einfach
mal der vollständigkeit halber also wie
gesagt olivenöl rein und dann das
fleisch kurz anbraten
[Musik]
nachdem das fleisch wirklich gerade so
ein bis zwei minuten scharf angebraten
wurde geben wir zwiebeln dazu und
tomatenmark tomatenmark gebe ich gerne
auch schon vorher mit den zugängen
entstehen richtig richtig tolle
röstaromen
[Musik]
so das hat jetzt auch vielleicht so eine
minute gedauert und jetzt kommen fast
alle anderen zutaten mit hinzu außer die
faden nudeln die tu ich mal ganz weit
weg nicht dass ich aus versehen mit rein
tobt weil sonst werden die richtig
matschig das ganze muss ja nicht gleich
richtig lange kochen
ich habe ja gesagt ich sage euch noch
was zu den zutaten wie man die
austauschen könnte
ich gebe zum beispiel die tomaten mit
hinzu und das frische tomaten wäre es
jetzt total eilig hat kann natürlich
auch kassierte nehmen aber frisch ist
natürlich irgendwie immer leckere und
aromatischer
dann gebe ich koriander sellerie und
petersilie dazu da gibt es natürlich
auch so die getrocknete variante aber
auch hier schmeckt frisch irgendwie
immer ein bisschen besser und intensiver
[Musik]
was die staudensellerie angeht
diese staude also diese stange die gebe
ich jetzt mit dazu ich habe es aber auch
mal mit und ohne gemacht denn ich hab
das rezept vorher dreimal getestet damit
wirklich perfekt ist und also ich finde
das minimale unterschied wenn ihr das
nicht mögen oder auch gar keine lust auf
diese ganze zubereitung vorher dann
machst es einfach weg die kichererbsen
die habe ich jetzt aus der dose genommen
aus dem türkischen supermarkt gibt es
für den araber und türken ist ganz
normal dass es die schon folgekosten der
dose gibt aber auch im reformhaus und
drogeriemarkt da gibt es ja auch immer
in gläsern und dann spart ihr euch
nämlich einfach den schritt wenn ihr
kontrolle zickig herbst müsst ihr nicht
24 stunden einweichen und dann könnt ihr
sie erst mit dazugeben und was die
linken angeht hier könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch rote linsen nehmen ich
habe zum beispiel immer rote linsen also
die hatte ich jetzt gar nicht da die
habe ich mir für die super extra gekauft
und rote linsen habe ich immer da allein
schon für die türkische linsensuppe und
die könnt ihr dann auch niemals ihr
müsst nicht extra die anderen kaufen was
die gewürze angeht kann ich euch sagen
natürlich salz und pfeffer gehören rein
das ist ganz klar zum pfeffer kann ich
muss sagen ich habe hier den weißen
pfeffer genommen ihr könnt aber auch den
dunklen nehmen weil das macht im
geschmack überhaupt keinen unterschied
hier geht es wirklich nur ums aussehen
beim ingwer könntet ihr natürlich auch
den frischen nämlich nehmen hier den
getrockneten das pulver sind ist ganz
typisch für die orientalische küche und
glaubt mir schmeckt total lecker also
falls solche selbst sind in der suppe
nannte schmidt superlecker zum gemeinen
kreuzkümmel kann ich sagen den müsst ihr
auf jeden fall rein tun wenn
kichererbsen mit drin sind denke ich
ersten haben ja eine art protein das ein
blähbauch verursacht und das hilft dem
entgegen also wenn ihr das nicht
reinmacht dann bekommt euch die suppe
nicht so gut so jetzt haben wir hier nur
noch unser kurkuma und das ist so ein
bisschen safran ersatz denn nicht jeder
bekommt überall safran her
und deswegen habe ich hier gucken
es sind alle zutaten drin einmal richtig
schön verrühren dass sich auch alles gut
verbindet dann geben wir noch bisschen
leitungswasser rein und dann bringen wir
das auch schon zum kochen
[Musik]
die hd die suppe fängt jetzt gerade an
zu kochen damit wir so eine richtige
hitze haben aber es ist einmal aufkochen
lassen gehe jetzt auf die mittlere stufe
und lasse das mit decke drüber
ungefähr so 40 45 minuten köcheln
ihr könnt da zwischendurch immer wieder
umrühren dann könnt ihr sicher stellen
dass im topf wohl nichts anbrennen wer
einen schnellkochtopf hat der staat sich
ein bisschen zeit dann dauert das ganze
15 minuten oder 20 aber ich habe leider
keinen deswegen warten geduldig
die hd da durfte jetzt 45 minuten
köcheln dabei habe ich auch uns so
umgerührt und jetzt müssen wir sie noch
an decken weil die noch viel zu
dünnflüssig ist und das ist auch so ein
bisschen typisch dass die ein bisschen
dicker ist deshalb habe ich mir hier
mehr vorbereitet und lauwarmes wasser
und das führe ich jetzt kurz klümpchen 2
und dann gehen wir das mit dazu
[Musik]
das verrät sich übrigens viel besser
wenn ihr warmes wasser an dem stoff
kaltes der und jetzt gebe ich das
einfach mit rein früher das und lass es
noch einmal aufkochen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen die farben oder dazu
also wirklich erst im allerletzten
schritt die brauchen ja nicht lange noch
ein paar minuten als einfach mit rein
geben und noch mal ein paar minuten
mitkochen lassen und dann seid ihr aber
wirklich fertig
[Musik]
übrigens habe ich noch einen tipp auf
lager
denn gerade nachdem ihr das andenken
lassen habt kann es wirklich passieren
dass euch der top wohnen anderen also
ich mach das mal so dass ich dann
wirklich alle 30 50 sekunden einmal kurz
am topfboden richtig gut umrühren damit
auch wirklich nichts passieren kann in
ihr wissen es gibt nicht ärgerlicheres
als dass es irgendwo anbrennt
[Musik]
das war es auch schon die harry die
suppe ist endlich fertig sie reicht
ungefähr für zwölf personen
das mag jetzt ein bisschen viel
vorkommen aber ihr macht euch einmal die
arbeit und habt ihr dann für morgen und
für übermorgen auch noch so viel kunst
auch sonst gerne einfrieren die schmeckt
wie neu
wenn ihr sie am nächsten tag ist dann
ist es ganz normal dass die ein wenig
dicker geworden ist dann gibt einfach
ein bisschen wasser drüber kurz auf und
es schmeckt wie neu ich empfehle euch
auch dass ihr zitronen serviert während
er die suppe ist denn das schmeckt noch
mal richtig lecker mit dieser säure
ansonsten freue ich mich natürlich wenn
ihr die suppe nach macht und meine fotos
zukommen es gerne über instagram mit dem
hashtag s kitchen die genauen
mengenangaben stehen wie immer unten in
der infobox und er macht auf jeden fall
nach
denn immer dann ohne harry die suppe ist
kein song war da aber es gehört einfach
auf jeden fall dazu und ich freue mich
wenn ihr beim nächsten mal auch wieder
eingeschaltet denn dann gibt es meine
rzytki das ist süß honig gebäck und das
ist ganz typisch dass man die mitte
herisau zusammen ist und das erwartet
euch dann im nächsten video chat
[Musik]
ganz erklären und batterien man bringt
wie so ein baum mit rein das ist ein
baum also praktisch
[Musik]